find the perimeter of this hexagon so
the perimeter just means the distance
around the object or if you add up all
of the lengths of the sides of the
object so we're going to add up all the
lengths of sides of this hexagon and
hexagon is just a six-sided geometrical
shape like this so to find the perimeter
we just need to find the distance around
the hexagon which is going to be the sum
of all of the lengths of the sides so
the perimeter is going to be 24 so how
many of these do we have we have one two
three four five six
24s which makes sense because the
hexagon has six sides so we're gonna
have 24 let me write this a little bit
bigger 24 plus we write it like this
plus 24 plus 24 plus 24 plus 24 and
let's see that's five 24 so we're going
24 so let's add them all at the same
time we could have done it piece by
piece but let's just go straight ahead
so let's go first at the ones place so 4
plus 4 4 plus 4 is 8
8 plus 4 is 12 12 plus 4 is 16 16 plus 4
is 20 20 plus 4 is 20 4 is 24 and now
we're in the tens place 2 plus 2 is 4
plus 2 is 6 plus 2 is 8 plus 2 is 10
plus 2 is 12 plus 2 is 14 plus 2 is 14
so the sum of these six 24s is 144 that
is the perimeter and when we learn
multiplication if you haven't learned it
already you could have done this simpler
you say you have 6 24 so this would
actually be a multiplication problem of
6 times 24 if you don't know how to do
that just yet don't worry about it you
can just add them all up you get 144